it's not surprising why companies are
backing away from a short form content
the reality is that creators are just
using shorts as a springboard
advertisers don't want to get involved
and audiences are by no means ditching
long-form content this isn't to say that
Tick Tock is going to die like Vine but
what has become abundantly clear is that
short form content is simply an addition
to long-form content not a replacement
like the media often suggests So Meta
and YouTube no longer feel threatened by
Tick Tock if anything it's actually a
tick tock that strives to be more like
meta and YouTube so that they don't end
up like Vine combine this with the
recession and it simply makes no sense
to bet so much on a historically flaky
medium and that's why companies are
already giving up and deploying back on
short form content